Hello. Hey there. Happy New Year. Angela. Happy 2026. Same to you, lady. I'm excited that we're kicking off the new year on office ladies with breakdowns of the paper. Same here. You know, I've really enjoyed watching them and sort of getting to know their whole world and breaking them down. And we're getting so many great contributions from the cast and crew. So I really feel like we are getting some insider scoop. I know everybody. I'm excited for Wednesday. So you can hear our first breakdown. Yeah. Well, let's jump into our tidbits for our second drink of branch wars. This is the episode where Karen is trying to steal Stanley from the Scranton branch.
你好。嘿。新年快乐。安吉拉。2026年快乐。你也一样，女士。我很兴奋我们能在《办公室女郎》节目中以解析《办公室》剧集的方式开启新的一年。我也是。你知道，我真的很喜欢观看这些剧集，去了解他们的整个世界并进行解析。我们从演职人员那里得到了很多很棒的贡献。所以我真的觉得我们得到了一些内幕消息。我知道，大家。我很期待周三。这样你们就能听到我们的第一次解析了。是的。好吧，让我们进入《分部战争》第二杯饮品的趣闻环节。这一集里，凯伦正试图从斯克兰顿分部挖走斯坦利。
Uh-huh. And it's also the Finer Things Club. Yes. Mm-hmm. So now this podcast episode starts with me saying, I'm going to hit you with a summary. Mm-hmm. And, Angela, you say that every time I say that, you sing in your head, hit me with your summaries every time come on and hit me with your summaries sorry okay go on yes well we got mail
嗯哼。而且还有“精致事物俱乐部”。是的。嗯哼。所以现在这一集播客开始时，我说，我要给你来个总结。嗯哼。而且，安吉拉，你说每次我这么说，你脑子里就会唱起，每次都用你的总结来打击我，来吧，用你的总结打击我，抱歉，好的，继续，是的，好吧，我们收到了邮件。
about it lady sonia g said ladies i love your podcast but i must point out that hit me with your best shot updated as hit me with your summaries it's by pat benatar wait what did i say you said joan yes and sonia said ladies we must not mix up our 80s hard rock god mothers oh i know it's pat benatar of course Oh, but I agree with you. I'm like, sure, Joan Jett, like we missed it, lady. Oh, Sonia, thank you. Mm-hmm. Ah, I love both of those ladies. You know, both Joan Jett and Pat Benatar were on my inspirational playlists for New Year's Reb and Ashland Avenue. I love them both. They're amazing. Yes. Okay, well, I have a fan catch from Amber L. She says, quote, not technically a question, but a prop catch. In one of the opening scenes of the episode, when the camera focuses in on the reception,
关于这件事，索尼娅·G说，女士们，我喜欢你们的播客，但我必须指出，那首歌是《Hit Me With Your Best Shot》，被改成了《Hit Me With Your Summaries》，那是帕特·班纳塔唱的。等等，我说了什么？你说的是琼·杰特，是的，索尼娅说，女士们，我们绝不能搞混我们80年代硬摇滚的教母。哦，我知道那是帕特·班纳塔，当然。哦，但我同意你的看法。我就想，没错，琼·杰特，就像我们错过了它一样，女士。哦，索尼娅，谢谢你。嗯哼。啊，我喜欢这两位女士。你知道，琼·杰特和帕特·班纳塔都在我的新年励志播放列表里。我都很喜欢她们。她们太棒了。是的。好吧，我有一个来自安珀·L的粉丝发现。她说，引用，不算是一个问题，而是一个道具发现。在这一集的开场场景之一中，当摄像机聚焦在接待处时，
desk in the Utica office, there is a box on the counter. It is a Holland Farms box. That bakery is a staple, and she put staple in all caps of Utica and Mohawk Valley culture. They have amazing donuts and half-moon cookies, very different from black and whites. And she grew up in the Utica area and loved this attention to detail that getting that specific box required. Well, first off, amazing attention to detail, like Amber said. I noticed that Amber sent us a link to these half-moon cookies, and I was going to surprise us by buying the cookies. Oh.
尤蒂卡办公室的桌子上有一个盒子。那是一个荷兰农场（Holland Farms）的盒子。那家面包店是尤蒂卡和莫霍克谷文化的主食，她把“主食”两个字全大写了。他们有很棒的甜甜圈和半月饼干，和黑白饼干非常不同。她在尤蒂卡地区长大，很喜欢这种需要特定盒子才能体现的对细节的关注。好吧，首先，非常棒的细节关注，就像安珀说的那样。我注意到安珀给我们发了一个这些半月饼干的链接，我本来想买这些饼干给我们一个惊喜。哦。
But I didn't. Oh. Because I looked at the website and 12 cookies costs $55.95. That felt like a lot to me. Am I crazy? That's a lot for a dozen cookies, right? Yeah. How big are these cookies?
但我没买。哦。因为我看了网站，12个饼干要55.95美元。我觉得这太贵了。我是不是疯了？一打饼干要这么多钱，对吧？是的。这些饼干有多大？
I mean, they look like normal-sized cookies. maybe this is just the cost to ship them across the country. Maybe so. If you go in person, they're not as much. Right, right. But it did get me thinking, maybe I should have done it because I have shipped myself Emo's pizza from St. Louis on dry ice before. Like, I did it for Christmas Eve one year.
我的意思是，它们看起来像正常大小的饼干。也许这就是把它们运往全国的成本。也许是这样。如果你亲自去买，就不会那么贵了。对，对。但这确实让我思考，也许我应该买的，因为我以前曾把自己从圣路易斯买的伊莫披萨（Emo's pizza）用干冰运过来。就像，有一年平安夜我这么做过。
I did it for my birthday one year. So I have shipped myself a hometown treat, you know, that's not inexpensive. Right. So if you want this. this hometown treat, you can get it. Have you ever done that? Have you ever? Oh, yeah. There is a smoked turkey that is the best damn smoked turkey you're ever going to have. Okay. It's from this little like mom and pop place in Texas. And when we host Thanksgiving, we get that turkey. You do. Yeah. Yeah. It's so good. Sometimes you need that taste of home. Yeah. Well, finally, Angela,
有一年我生日我也这么做了。所以我曾把自己家乡的美味运过来，你知道，那并不便宜。对。所以如果你想要这个家乡的美味，你可以买到。你做过这种事吗？你做过吗？哦，是的。有一种烟熏火鸡，那是你吃过最棒的烟熏火鸡。好的。它来自德克萨斯州的一家小夫妻店。当我们举办感恩节聚会时，我们就会买那只火鸡。你真的买了？是的。是的。太好吃了。有时候你需要那种家乡的味道。是的。好吧，最后，安吉拉，
we got two letters about John Krasinski's accent that I have to share. Really? Yes. Stacey S said, first off, I want to say, I love, love your podcast. I've been a fan from the very beginning. I also love hearing about how close a friendship you to have and I find it so sweet. Anyway, I wanted to bring up from this episode that there is a scene where Jim is in the car and it's right before Karen catches him and he says, oh my God, oh my God, and you can totally hear his Boston accent. Did he do that on purpose or was it a slip? Either way, it was really funny. All right, Stacey, I grabbed an audio clip. I'm going to be honest, I don't hear it. So I backed up this clip for two reasons. One, I just wanted to give it a little bit of a runway, but also my favorite part of this episode
我们收到了两封关于约翰·卡拉辛斯基口音的信，我必须分享一下。真的吗？是的。斯泰西·S说，首先，我想说，我爱死你们的播客了。我从一开始就是粉丝。我也很喜欢听你们谈论彼此之间深厚的友谊，我觉得太甜了。总之，我想提一下这一集里有一个场景，吉姆在车里，就在凯伦抓住他之前，他说，哦我的天，哦我的天，你可以完全听出他的波士顿口音。他是故意的还是口误？不管怎样，这真的很有趣。好吧，斯泰西，我抓取了一个音频片段。老实说，我没听出来。所以我备份了这个片段有两个原因。第一，我只是想给它留一点余地，但我也觉得这一集我最喜欢的部分
is this exchange on the walkie-talkie when Dwight and Michael are trying to steal the copier and Jim is trying to discourage them from doing these shenanigans. It just makes me happy. So we're going to listen to that and it's going to lead into the, Oh, my God, oh my God that Stacey is talking about.
是当德怀特和迈克尔试图偷复印机，而吉姆试图劝阻他们不要搞这些恶作剧时，对讲机里的那段对话。这让我很开心。所以我们要听听那段，它会引出斯泰西提到的那个“哦我的天，哦我的天”。
Okay, and we're going to see if we hear the Boston access. Yes, it'll be at the end. All right, great, Scott. If you found that choking hazard poster, just head on home. We've got something far better. They're Crown Jewel. They're industrial copier. Isn't that thing huge?
好的，我们要看看能不能听到波士顿口音。是的，它会在最后。好的，太棒了。如果你找到了那个窒息危险的海报，就回家吧。我们有更好的东西。他们的镇店之宝。他们的工业复印机。那东西不是很大吗？
It's enormous, but it's got wheels. We're wheeling it down the hall into the stairwell. Get the car ready. Keep the engine running. No, that is a terrible idea. Don't do this. No! My hip bone.
它非常巨大，但它有轮子。我们正把它推下走廊进入楼梯间。准备好车。保持引擎运转。不，那是个糟糕的主意。别这么做。不！我的髋骨。
Overwish between the cuff here and they're really... Oh, God. Oh, my leg, Jim. Leave us, Jim. Help leave us. No. Save yourself. Don't leave us.
在复印机之间，它们真的……哦，天哪。哦，我的腿，吉姆。离开我们，吉姆。帮帮我们，离开我们。不。救你自己。别离开我们。
Help us. We need help, Jim. Okay, first of all, stop using my name. And second of all, just... God, you gotta move out. Damn it, guys. Strike. Just move over a little bit.
帮帮我们。我们需要帮助，吉姆。好的，首先，别再叫我的名字了。第二，只是……天哪，你们得搬走。该死，伙计们。罢工。稍微挪一下。
I'm on the control of my bladder. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Karen is back. Is that Karen? Take her to a motel. Make love to her, Jim. No, I'm not...
我控制不住我的膀胱了。哦，我的天。哦，我的天。凯伦回来了。那是凯伦吗？带她去汽车旅馆。和她做爱，吉姆。不，我不是……
That's it. I do hear it. You hear it. I hear it because he goes, oh, my God. Oh, my God. Okay. Yeah. All right.
就是这样。我确实听到了。你听到了。我听到了，因为他说，哦，我的天。哦，我的天。好的。是的。好吧。
I totally hear it. Excellent. Well, next up, we got this letter from Megan L. who said, quote, I emailed this question, but I'm resubmitting it here in hopes of a season four second drink episode. Oh, Megan. You've stuck with it for a bit. I know.
我完全听到了。太棒了。好吧，接下来，我们收到了梅根·L的这封信，她说，引用，我发邮件问过这个问题，但我在这里重新提交，希望能有第四季的第二杯饮品剧集。哦，梅根。你坚持了一段时间了。我知道。
How was John Krasinski's Irish accent so good and why was it in the episode? Did the writer want him to do it? Did he have to practice? Is it something he was already good at? did John want to do it? His accent was just really impressive. Megan. Megan. Megan. This is just John. He is notoriously good at accents. Yeah. He's like a parrot. He is a great mimic. Yeah. And he's just really funny with that. He gets the timing. He gets the nuance of the accent. Yes. Yeah. And basically, once the writers knew this about John, they just started
约翰·卡拉辛斯基的爱尔兰口音怎么那么好，为什么它会出现在这一集里？是编剧想让他这么做吗？他需要练习吗？这是他本来就擅长的吗？约翰想这么做吗？他的口音真的很令人印象深刻。梅根。梅根。梅根。这就是约翰。他以擅长口音而闻名。是的。他就像一只鹦鹉。他是一个伟大的模仿者。是的。而且他在那方面真的很风趣。他掌握了时机。他掌握了口音的细微差别。是的。是的。基本上，一旦编剧们知道了约翰的这一点，他们就开始
writing it into a lot of episodes. And that's what our writers would do. They would discover sort of like our little hidden talents and just sprinkle them in. Yep. All right, everyone, that's all we got. Now, here is your second drink of Branch Wars. Have a great Monday, and we'll see you Wednesday for a new episode of Office Ladies 6.0. I hope you have a wicket good time.
把它写进了很多剧集里。这就是我们的编剧会做的事情。他们会发现我们的一些小隐藏天赋，然后把它们点缀进去。是的。好吧，各位，这就是我们所有的内容了。现在，这是你们的《分部战争》第二杯饮品。祝大家周一愉快，我们周三见，届时将播出《办公室女郎》6.0的新一集。希望你们玩得开心。
Oh, my God. Oh, my God. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office. watch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give
哦，我的天。哦，我的天。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》观看播客。每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供
exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office Ladies. Get out your faky stashes, everybody, because it's time for branch wars. Fanky Stash Day on Office Ladies. It's season four, episode 10, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Joss Whedon. There's so much good fake stash. Stash is lingo for mustache. Oh, Jenna, thank you. Thank you for breaking that down for us.
只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女郎》。拿出你们的假胡子，各位，因为《分部战争》的时间到了。《办公室女郎》的假胡子日。这是第四季第10集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，乔斯·韦登导演。有很多很棒的假胡子。胡子是小胡子的行话。哦，珍娜，谢谢你。谢谢你为我们解析。
I wanted to break it down. I break down everything on office ladies. It's what we do. I'm going to hit you with a summary. Guys, Karen is back. She is now the regional manager of the Utica branch, and she offers Stanley a higher-paying job to leave Scranton. Guess what Michael's reaction is to that?
我想解析它。我在《办公室女郎》里解析一切。这就是我们所做的。我要给你来个总结。伙计们，凯伦回来了。她现在是尤蒂卡分部的区域经理，她给斯坦利提供了一份薪水更高的工作，让他离开斯克兰顿。猜猜迈克尔对此的反应是什么？
he flips out yes very much so meanwhile pam oscar and toby have created a finer things club it's finer things club you're so excited and he tries to join but he's rejected and michael and dwight trick jim into going on a sales call but they actually take him to utica to prank karen as a revenge for trying to poach stanley that's a lot this was a big episode for us i mean anytime we traveled, you know, it was a big deal. This is something I have to say to you. I have to get this off my chest, Jenna. There's been a few times that you say, I'm going to hit you with the summary. Okay. And every time, the only thing going through my brain is, hit me with the summary. I'm going to hit you with a summary. What song are you singing? I'm trying to sing,
他崩溃了，是的，非常严重。与此同时，帕姆、奥斯卡和托比创建了一个“精致事物俱乐部”。是“精致事物俱乐部”，你太兴奋了，他试图加入，但被拒绝了。迈克尔和德怀特诱骗吉姆去进行一次销售拜访，但他们实际上把他带到了尤蒂卡，去恶作剧凯伦，作为她试图挖走斯坦利的报复。这内容很多。这对我们来说是一集大制作。我的意思是，任何时候我们出差，你知道，那都是一件大事。这是我必须对你说的话。我必须把这件事说出来，珍娜。有几次你说，我要给你来个总结。好的。每次，我脑子里唯一闪过的就是，用你的总结来打击我。我要给你来个总结。你在唱什么歌？我试图唱，
Hit me with your best shot. Oh, I thought you were singing, hit me with your summary. Did you hear that. That was Brittany. Yeah. Well, anyway, I hear Joan Jett. Well, I'm glad you got that off your chest, because God forbid you would have had to carry that through this whole podcast. You know what? It was weighing on me, and I feel lighter. Good. Fastback number one. Like I said earlier, this episode was written by Mindy Kaling. This was the seventh episode she had written and she was nominated for Outstanding writing in a comedy series in the 2008 NAACP Image Awards for this episode. Yay, Mindy! Yay, Mindy!
用你最好的镜头来打击我。哦，我以为你在唱，用你的总结来打击我。你听到了吗？那是布兰妮。是的。好吧，总之，我听到的是琼·杰特。好吧，我很高兴你把它说出来了，因为天哪，如果你不得不带着这个念头录完整个播客。你知道吗？它一直压在我心头，现在我感觉轻松多了。很好。快讯第一条。就像我之前说的，这一集是由敏迪·卡灵编剧的。这是她编剧的第七集，她凭借这一集获得了2008年NAACP形象奖喜剧类杰出编剧提名。耶，敏迪！耶，敏迪！
When I was looking at Mindy's award history, I found this. What? I mean, Mindy has been nominated up and down. Emmys and things, and she's winning things, she's celebrated. Deservedly so. The lady is very talented. In 2013, Time Magazine listed Mindy as one of the 100 most influential people in the world.
当我查看敏迪的获奖历史时，我发现了这个。什么？我的意思是，敏迪被提名了很多次。艾美奖之类的，她赢得了奖项，她受到了赞誉。这是她应得的。这位女士非常有才华。2013年，《时代》杂志将敏迪列为世界上100位最具影响力的人物之一。
Dang, Mindy. You guys have to understand. Like, Mindy was on the office with us and we're all like just getting our hair and makeup done and she's in her 20s and we're just being girlfriends and now she is just a force, just a powerhouse. And we always knew that she was super smart and talented and just, this is awesome. I love that all her dreams have come true. Yes.
该死，敏迪。你们必须明白。就像，敏迪和我们一起在《办公室》，我们都在做头发和化妆，她才20多岁，我们只是闺蜜，现在她简直是一股力量，一个强人。我们一直都知道她超级聪明、有才华，这太棒了。我喜欢她所有的梦想都成真了。是的。
And she's a mom, and I know that was a big dream. I know. I'm just so happy for her. Mindy, we love you. We're here for it, Mindy. We're here for it. We will be your girl gang cheering you on. Super proud.
而且她是一位母亲，我知道那是一个大梦想。我知道。我真为她高兴。敏迪，我们爱你。我们支持你，敏迪。我们支持你。我们将成为你的闺蜜团，为你加油。超级骄傲。
All right, fast fact number two. Okay. Fan question from Ryan, Annika, and Vivian Fruitman. Where did you film the Utica office? Oh, some cantipedia coming. I feel it. You know it. It's a location breakdown.
好吧，快讯第二条。好的。来自瑞安、安妮卡和薇薇安·弗鲁特曼的粉丝提问。你们在哪里拍摄的尤蒂卡办公室？哦，百科全书式的知识要来了。我感觉到了。你知道的。这是一个外景解析。
So, Angie, you know, we've talked a lot about how oftentimes we would build a temporary set for another office. Like, we built corporate over on our warehouse stages. Mm-hmm. Well, Kent told me that the size of the Utica, Dundermifflin branch, was just way too big and way too costly. So they took it on location. They found a business park in Canoga Park, and this building had a very large,
所以，安吉，你知道，我们谈论过很多次，我们经常会为另一个办公室搭建临时布景。就像，我们在仓库舞台上搭建了公司总部。嗯哼。好吧，肯特告诉我，尤蒂卡邓德·米夫林分部的规模实在太大了，成本太高了。所以他们选择了外景。他们在卡诺加公园找到了一个商业园区，这栋建筑有一个非常大的、
empty office suite. So our set decorators just went in and decorated it to be Dunder Mifflin Utica. And then they also filmed all the park. lot scenes in that same Kenoga Park business lot. I remember we were on the road for this episode because it also meant I had a few days off in the middle of the week. That was always very exciting. When you would read a script and there were a bunch of characters who went somewhere and you didn't go, you were like, oh my gosh, doctor's appointments. What else can I do that I can normally never do? Exactly. Well, we did not go to this business park for this episode,
空的办公套房。所以我们的布景装饰师就进去把它装饰成了邓德·米夫林尤蒂卡分部。然后他们还在同一个卡诺加公园的商业园区拍摄了所有的停车场场景。我记得我们为了这一集在路上，因为这也意味着我在周中有了几天假。那总是非常令人兴奋。当你读到剧本，发现有一群角色去了某个地方而你没去，你会想，哦天哪，医生预约。我还能做些什么我平时永远做不了的事情？完全正确。好吧，我们没有去这个商业园区拍摄这一集，
but I end up going back in lecture circuit because we go back to Utica. That was an episode that also written by Mindy Kaling. It was crazy because the set decorators, after they build a set somewhere, we have to leave. They have to break it all down. But before they do, they take detailed pictures, like just extensive photos of every nook, every desk, every placement of every item on the off chance that we have to go back and recreate it. And that's what they had to do with the Utica branch. Yeah, it's pretty fascinating. They have these binders, the different departments. And hair and makeup do this as well so that, you know, if there were people that were guest actors in the Utica branch, they match their looks. But also our set designers would do this.
但我最终在《讲座巡回》那一集又回去了，因为我们回到了尤蒂卡。那一集也是敏迪·卡灵编剧的。这很疯狂，因为布景装饰师在某个地方搭建布景后，我们必须离开。他们必须拆除它。但在拆除之前，他们会拍摄详细的照片，就像对每个角落、每张桌子、每件物品的摆放位置进行大量的拍照，以防万一我们必须回去重建它。这就是他们对尤蒂卡分部所做的事情。是的，这非常迷人。他们有这些活页夹，不同的部门。发型和化妆部门也这样做，这样，你知道，如果尤蒂卡分部有客串演员，他们可以匹配他们的造型。但我们的布景设计师也会这样做。
And I looked through one of these binders one time, Jenna. And it is so thorough. I was so impressed. Yeah. Just photo after photo after photo. And they take all the stuff and they store it in that big warehouse that we've talked about. And they label it all. It's really crazy.
有一次我翻看了其中一个活页夹，珍娜。它非常详尽。我印象非常深刻。是的。照片一张接一张。他们把所有的东西都拿走，存放在我们谈论过的那个大仓库里。他们给所有东西贴上标签。这真的很疯狂。
It was very organized and I liked it. I liked it, too. You know, I love good organization. I know you do. And I know you liked it, Angela, because it involved a lot of bins. Ben's and I love photos. I will look through any photo album. This is a little kinsie tidbit about myself. I love looking at pictures. And I don't need to know the people in them. I remember one time, when we were getting married, we were looking at wedding photographers and they would send us their other albums so we could see their style. Yeah. Fascinating. Total strangers. I love it. Well, I have some good follows for you on Instagram. Oh, yeah?
它非常有条理，我喜欢。我也喜欢。你知道，我喜欢好的组织。我知道你喜欢。我知道你喜欢它，安吉拉，因为它涉及很多箱子。箱子，而且我喜欢照片。我会翻看任何相册。这是关于我自己的一个小金赛趣闻。我喜欢看照片。而且我不需要认识照片里的人。我记得有一次，当我们结婚时，我们在看婚礼摄影师，他们会把他们的其他相册发给我们，这样我们就能看到他们的风格。是的。迷人。完全陌生的人。我喜欢。好吧，我在Instagram上有一些很好的关注推荐给你。哦，是吗？
Of just random photo albums? No, it's of wedding photos. I also, by the way, love looking at wedding photos. People are so happy on their wedding day. It's so joyous. It's joyous, Jenna. But then there's also a story. Like, every wedding has like, you know, the drunk uncle or the aunt who's alone on the dance floor.
只是随机的相册？不，是婚礼照片。顺便说一句，我也喜欢看婚礼照片。人们在婚礼当天太幸福了。太欢乐了。这很欢乐，珍娜。但背后也有故事。就像，每场婚礼都有，你知道，喝醉的叔叔或者独自在舞池里的阿姨。
It's so good. And then the way they decorate their table, you know, you'll see, oh, look, they've got a pair of bicycles on top of their wedding cake. They must love cycling. Yes, they're the bicycle couple. Yeah. Okay, well, hit me up with some Instagrams. I will. You know what, guys? If you are interested, we'll link to it in our stories. I'll link my favorite bridal Instagram follows on Office Ladies' Pod. Guys, that was quite a tangent and also an example of what a phone call might be between Angela and I. Next up is fast fact number three. Since we're talking about the Utica branch, I actually thought this might be a good time to break down the various branches of
太棒了。还有他们装饰桌子的方式，你知道，你会看到，哦看，他们的婚礼蛋糕上有一对自行车。他们一定很喜欢骑自行车。是的，他们是自行车夫妇。是的。好吧，给我推荐一些Instagram账号。我会的。你知道吗，伙计们？如果你感兴趣，我们会在我们的故事里放上链接。我会在Office Ladies' Pod上链接我最喜欢的婚礼Instagram关注账号。伙计们，那真是个离题的话题，也是安吉拉和我之间电话通话的一个例子。接下来是快讯第三条。既然我们在谈论尤蒂卡分部，我实际上认为现在是解析邓德·米夫林各个分部的好时机，
Dunder Mifflin because, lady, I realize we've never done this. Oh, we need to do it. And, oh, okay, I have something to piggyback off this, but you go first. Oh, okay. Well, we all know that the headquarters of Dunder Mifflin is in New York. Yes. But there are currently six active regional branches located across the United States. They are in Akron, Ohio, Nashua, New Hampshire, Hampshire, Rochester, Syracuse, and Utica, which are all in New York State, and Scranton, Pennsylvania. Now, the company used to be much larger. You might remember, in the Boys and Girls episode, Jan mentioned there used to be a branch in Pittsfield, but it was closed because they tried to unionize. And then in future episodes, we will learn about branches in Camden and Yonkers, which got closed due to the economy, and Buffalo, which was also closed.
因为，女士，我意识到我们从来没做过这个。哦，我们需要做。而且，哦，好的，我有一些关于这个的补充，但你先说。哦，好的。好吧，我们都知道邓德·米夫林的总部在纽约。是的。但目前在美国各地有六个活跃的区域分部。它们位于俄亥俄州阿克伦、新罕布什尔州纳舒厄、罗切斯特、锡拉丘兹和尤蒂卡（都在纽约州），以及宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿。现在，这家公司曾经规模大得多。你可能记得，在《男孩和女孩》那一集里，简提到曾经有一个皮茨菲尔德分部，但它关闭了，因为他们试图成立工会。然后在未来的剧集中，我们将了解到卡姆登和扬克斯的分部，它们因经济原因关闭了，还有布法罗分部，也关闭了。
Buffalo, which was the home of Denise Stimms, Angela's party planning committee rival. Closes down. Bye-bye, Denise. Oh, Angela Martin is so happy. And in our final season, we learned that there was also a branch in Binghamton. So there you go. There's a great deleted scene. It's a talking head where Michael goes through the other branches and sort of like gives you a little insight on how he remembers them.
布法罗，那是安吉拉的派对策划委员会竞争对手丹妮丝·斯蒂姆斯的老家。关闭了。再见，丹妮丝。哦，安吉拉·马丁太高兴了。在最后一季，我们了解到还有一个宾汉姆顿分部。所以就是这样。有一个很棒的删减片段。那是一个谈话头，迈克尔回顾了其他分部，并给了你一点关于他如何记住它们的见解。
It's really funny. And Sam, I actually, I would love for you to play it right now. Utica is Snoosville. Albany are the prepsters. Nashua, no parking. Akron is haunted. Camden is in a basement. Yonkers has a two hot girls.
这真的很有趣。萨姆，我实际上，我很想让你现在播放它。尤蒂卡是无聊小镇。奥尔巴尼是预科生。纳舒厄，没停车位。阿克伦闹鬼。卡姆登在地下室。扬克斯有两个辣妹。
And here in Scranton, we are the cool guys. That is amazing. Yeah. Yep. He's sort of talking about the fact that, like, why would Stanley want to leave here? We're the cool guys. and then he lists all the other branches, and it just cracked me up. I love that Nashua, no parking.
而在斯克兰顿，我们是酷哥们。这太棒了。是的。是的。他是在谈论这样一个事实，即为什么斯坦利想离开这里？我们是酷哥们。然后他列出了所有其他分部，这让我笑死了。我喜欢纳舒厄，没停车位。
That made me laugh. I loved no parking, too. That was my favorite. Lady, that's all I got. Well, those are great fast facts. I can't wait to get in this episode. I have some mini dive on the Finer Things Club. Oh.
那让我笑了。我也喜欢没停车位。那是我的最爱。女士，这就是我所有的内容了。好吧，这些都是很棒的快讯。我迫不及待想进入这一集了。我有一些关于“精致事物俱乐部”的小深度解析。哦。
I love that you mini dived on the Finer Things Club. We will be back right after a break. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe, like, you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah.
我喜欢你对“精致事物俱乐部”进行了小深度解析。我们休息后马上回来。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，仅仅因为是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个全新的你。但也许你想成为一个负担较轻的你，一个更清醒的你。不是一个全新的你，但也许，就像，你只是想磨练一下。你想精益求精。是的。
I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you to. down, what might be holding you back? You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Because those really just add up. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over five million
我喜欢那个。精益求精。好吧，心理治疗可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么可能在阻碍你？你可以更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正试图放下对小事的压力。因为那些真的会累积起来。而且一切都会好起来的。好吧，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp的治疗师可以提供帮助。拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已经服务了超过五百万
people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better h-elp.com slash office ladies. All right, well, we are back and there is an establishing shot of the Utica branch office. We see that it is in the Mohawk Valley Center. It's the 2400 address. But at 2480, there's Wendale Flores of Utica. Oh. Yeah. If you need flowers.
全球用户。BetterHelp让你很容易在线匹配到合格的治疗师。注册并在betterhelp.com/office ladies获得10%的折扣。那是better h-elp.com/office ladies。好吧，我们回来了，尤蒂卡分部办公室有一个建立镜头。我们看到它在莫霍克谷中心。地址是2400号。但在2480号，有尤蒂卡的温代尔花店。哦。是的。如果你需要花的话。
We share an office with Bob Vance. They have the florist shop next door. That's nice. That is nice. And then at 0.06 seconds, everybody, there is a plant at reception. Utica plant at reception alert. Green leafy plant. It's over Rolando's shoulder.
我们和鲍勃·万斯共用一个办公室。他们隔壁有花店。那很好。那确实很好。然后在0.06秒，各位，接待处有一株植物。尤蒂卡接待处植物警报。绿色叶子植物。它在罗兰多的肩膀上方。
But sitting right in front of him, for everyone to enjoy, is a big box of donuts. Yeah. What the heck? Pam has a candy dish on her desk. Rolando has some donuts and we got a lot of mail about these donuts, Angela. Did we? Yes, we did. Clay LaFriends, Kaylee Gassner, Zach Mutolo, Amber Lee, Danny Hamilton, and many others said,
但坐在他面前，供大家享用的是一大盒甜甜圈。是的。搞什么鬼？帕姆的桌上有糖果盘。罗兰多有一些甜甜圈，我们收到了很多关于这些甜甜圈的邮件，安吉拉。是吗？是的，我们收到了。克莱·拉弗伦兹、凯莉·加斯纳、扎克·穆托洛、安珀·李、丹尼·汉密尔顿和其他许多人说，
Those donuts are from Holland Farms, which is an awesome regional bakery in the Utica area. Aw! They're famous for their jellyballs and half moon or black and white cookies. Everyone was very impressed. They said, we just loved whoever did research for this episode that they would dive this deep into Utica and have this amazing prop. That is Phil Shea. Phil Shea! Regional Prop Alert.
那些甜甜圈来自荷兰农场，这是尤蒂卡地区一家很棒的区域面包店。啊！他们以果冻球和半月饼干或黑白饼干而闻名。每个人都印象深刻。他们说，我们只是喜欢为这一集做研究的人，他们会深入挖掘尤蒂卡并拥有这个很棒的道具。那是菲尔·谢。菲尔·谢！区域道具警报。
I want a jelly. ball. That's what she said. Maybe she doesn't want a jellyball. So far, Rolando's front reception is kind of kicking Pam's ass. You know what? I've seen donuts in our break room. I'm talking about front reception right now. Wow. Okay. I'm talking a tiny, tiny container of jelly beans versus a whole amazing box of donuts. We don't know that Rolando, put those donuts there. Anyone could have brought those in. Yes, he did.
我想要一个果冻球。那是她说的。也许她不想要果冻球。到目前为止，罗兰多的前台接待处有点把帕姆比下去了。你知道吗？我在我们的休息室见过甜甜圈。我现在说的是前台接待处。哇。好吧。我说的是一个极小的果冻豆容器，而对方是一整盒很棒的甜甜圈。我们不知道罗兰多是不是把那些甜甜圈放在那里的。任何人都可以带进来。是的，他带的。
Rolanda was played by Adam Jamal Craig. You guys might recognize him because he went on to play Dominic on NCIS Los Angeles. I reached out to him to see if he remembered doing this episode and if he had any memories he could share and he sent in this awesome audio clip. Oh! Sam, will you play the clip? Yes, I totally remember, you know, spending a little bit of time shooting that with you guys. And it was, at the time, it was my big break.
罗兰多由亚当·贾马尔·克雷格饰演。你们可能认出他，因为他后来在《海军罪案调查处：洛杉矶》中饰演多米尼克。我联系了他，看看他是否记得拍摄这一集，以及他是否有任何可以分享的回忆，他发来了这段很棒的音频片段。哦！萨姆，你能播放这段片段吗？是的，我完全记得，你知道，和你们一起拍摄那段戏花了一点时间。而且在当时，那是我的重大突破。
Because I, you know, I had done a few co-stars and that was like, that was a big deal. And I just remember when I met the cast, one of the striking things was just how tall everyone was. Like, you know, just a, just a generally a tall cast that doesn't really translate on screen. But I also remember how kind everyone was. Like, it was just a really warm set, you know, because a lot of people who don't work in show business don't realize that not every set is a warm set. But that set was a very warm set. Like, everyone was really kind. But, man, it was a good time.
因为我，你知道，我做过几次联合主演，那就像，那是一件大事。我记得当我见到演员阵容时，最引人注目的一点就是每个人都那么高。就像，你知道，只是一个，只是一个普遍很高的演员阵容，这在屏幕上并没有真正体现出来。但我也记得每个人都多么友善。就像，那是一个非常温暖的剧组，你知道，因为很多不在演艺圈工作的人没有意识到并非每个剧组都是温暖的剧组。但那个剧组非常温暖。就像，每个人都真的很友善。但是，伙计，那是一段美好的时光。
And what's funny is, like, I've done things since then. Not long after that, I was on a series regular on a show. But still, no one cared about that. They all were like, I heard you were on the office. Like, when I get recognized, 99% of the time, it's from the office, not anything else. And so it was definitely a privilege and a joy to be, like, a part of that production. Aw, that is so sweet. You know, we did have a tall cast.
有趣的是，就像，从那以后我做过很多事情。在那之后不久，我就成为了一部剧的常规演员。但仍然，没人关心那个。他们都说，我听说你演过《办公室》。就像，当我被认出来时，99%的情况下，是因为《办公室》，而不是其他任何东西。所以能成为那部作品的一部分，绝对是一种荣幸和快乐。啊，那太甜了。你知道，我们确实有一个高个子演员阵容。
We've talked a little bit about it. All these guys were really tall. Yeah, we had a lot of tall fellas. We really did. Adam also told me that he had not watched the whole office series until this last year. Oh, yeah. And he was like, it is so good. And I said, I know, we're rewatching it.
我们谈论过一点。这些家伙真的很高。是的，我们有很多高个子。我们确实有。亚当还告诉我，直到去年他才看完整个《办公室》系列。哦，是的。他说，这太好了。我说，我知道，我们正在重温它。
And I feel the same way. I know. It was so crazy. Well, guys, Adam has a couple of cool projects he's working on now. One is called The Zook Line, and it's a show about this obscure dance you do with a partner called the Brazilian Zook. Oh, my gosh. Yes, Angela, if you go to his Instagram, he has all of these amazing dance videos. He also has another show called The Grownups, which is a roundtable discussion about current events, but through the lens that everyone is trying to get along as they talk about current events.
我也感觉一样。我知道。这太疯狂了。好吧，伙计们，亚当现在正在进行几个很酷的项目。一个是叫《祖克线》，这是一个关于你和舞伴跳的一种晦涩舞蹈的节目，叫巴西祖克。哦，天哪。是的，安吉拉，如果你去他的Instagram，他有所有这些很棒的舞蹈视频。他还有另一个节目叫《成年人》，这是一个关于时事的圆桌讨论，但通过每个人在谈论时事时都试图和睦相处的视角。
I was intrigued. Yeah. You can find both projects on his Instagram at Adam J. Craig. So check it out. And thank you, Adam. Thank you, Adam. Well, now we're into Karen's office. I mean, she looks fantastic in this whole episode. I thought, Rashida, you looked gorgeous. And her office is so professional. And it cuts back between Karen and Michael's offices. And I mean, come on. Michael is setting up a Ferris Bueller's prank. His desk is covered with like toys. Karen's desk looks like a badass boss lady. Yes, an adult works in Karen.
我很感兴趣。是的。你可以在他的Instagram @AdamJ.Craig上找到这两个项目。所以去看看吧。谢谢你，亚当。谢谢你，亚当。好吧，现在我们进入凯伦的办公室。我的意思是，她在这一整集里看起来棒极了。我觉得，拉什达，你看起来美极了。她的办公室非常专业。镜头在凯伦和迈克尔的办公室之间切换。我的意思是，得了吧。迈克尔正在设置一个《春天不是读书天》的恶作剧。他的桌子上摆满了玩具。凯伦的桌子看起来像个坏蛋女老板。是的，成年人工作空间。
An adult workspace. It's true. Well, we find out in this phone call that Karen is trying to hire someone from the Scranton branch. Yeah, she's like, hey, I'm glad we finally connected. We'd love to have you. And I'm like, who's she talking to? Well, then we cut to Michael's office. And like you said, he's got a dummy on his desk with this elaborate pulley system.
成年人工作空间。这是真的。好吧，我们在这次通话中发现凯伦正试图从斯克兰顿分部雇佣某人。是的，她说，嘿，我很高兴我们终于联系上了。我们很乐意让你加入。我就想，她在和谁说话？好吧，然后我们切到迈克尔的办公室。就像你说的，他的桌子上有一个假人，配有复杂的滑轮系统。
Yeah, this whole pulley with the dummy hand and it hits the snoring sound. this is what Ferris did. So his parents thought he was home when he went and played hookie. Yeah. And Michael is so elated by this. Dwight's excited. Stanley walks in and they're like, oh, Stanley, yes. We're going to test this out on you.
是的，整个滑轮配上假手，它会发出打呼噜的声音。这就是费里斯做的。所以他的父母以为他在家，而他去逃学了。是的。迈克尔对此感到非常欣喜。德怀特很兴奋。斯坦利走进来，他们说，哦，斯坦利，是的。我们要用你来测试一下。
And Stanley just no nonsense. It's like, Karen offered me more money. I'm going to Utica. And he walks out. I know. He also has that great line where he says, why is you being asleep at your desk better than not being here? We had a fan question for a friend question from
斯坦利只是不废话。他说，凯伦给了我更多的钱。我要去尤蒂卡。然后他走了出去。我知道。他还有那句很棒的台词，他说，为什么你在桌子上睡觉比不在这里更好？我们有一个粉丝提问，来自
Eric Wilson, I was wondering if you actually had a pulley system or if someone off camera was moving the arm. No, it was a real pulley system. They really built that. Yeah, it really worked. And it was really funny. And when the hand goes up at the end, when Stanley leaves, that really happened. That's my favorite part. It's such a good button to the scene. I know. Well, Michael goes out into the bullpen and he breaks the news that Stanley is leaving Scranton for Utica. He's been offered more money and everybody applauds. Everyone's like, congratulations, Stanley. And Michael's like, no, no. Yeah, Michael's totally upset. Well, at two minutes, 12 seconds, you'll see how they got all of us in the shot. If you look over, the camera whips over to accounting. And we did that thing where we all kind
埃里克·威尔逊，我想知道你们是否真的有一个滑轮系统，还是有幕后人员在移动手臂。不，那是一个真正的滑轮系统。他们真的搭建了那个。是的，它真的起作用了。而且它真的很有趣。当最后斯坦利离开时，手举起来，那真的发生了。那是我最喜欢的部分。那是这一幕最好的点缀。我知道。好吧，迈克尔走到办公区，宣布斯坦利要离开斯克兰顿去尤蒂卡的消息。他得到了更多的钱，每个人都鼓掌。每个人都说，恭喜你，斯坦利。迈克尔说，不，不。是的，迈克尔完全心烦意乱。好吧，在2分12秒，你们会看到他们是如何把我们所有人都拍进去的。如果你看过去，摄像机扫向会计部。我们做了那种我们都从桌子后面出来的事情。在2分12秒，你们可以看到我疯狂的装束，就像一件非常蓬松的衬衫配上背心，还有猫咪纽扣。就在我身后是那个婴儿爵士海报。它又挂起来了？它又挂起来了。哦，有没有删减片段解释这个？没有。2分12秒，婴儿海报在那里。
of come out from our desks. And at two minutes, 12 seconds, you guys can see my insane outfit, which is like a very floofy blouse with the vest, with the cat buttons. And right behind me is the baby jazz poster. It's back up? It's back up. Ooh, is there a deleted scene that explains this? No. Two minutes, 12 seconds, the baby poster is there.
爵士回来了。爵士回来了。我希望那些喜欢背景的人也能捕捉到这一刻。2分17秒。当迈克尔宣布斯坦利要离开时。菲利斯的脸，她看着他。太真实了。我告诉你，在我看来，菲利斯不知道。你会认为菲利斯和斯坦利会聊过这个。但菲利斯选择的表演方式就像是，斯坦利。是的，被背叛了。好吧，更像是敬畏。就像，看看你。哦，我得回去看看那个。哦，现在我们进入“精致事物俱乐部”。哦，我的天。我喜欢你对它如此兴奋。
Jazz is back. Jazz is back. And I want the folks that love the background to also catch this moment. Two minutes, 17 seconds. When Michael announces that Stanley's leaving. Phyllis's face, she looks at him. It's so honest. And I'm telling you, in my opinion, Phyllis didn't know. You would think Phyllis and Stanley would have chatted about this. But the way Phyllis chose to play it was like, Stanley. Yes, betrayed. Well, just more like in awe. Like, look at you go. Oh, I got to go back and look at that. Ooh, now we get into the Finer Things Club. Oh, my God. I love how you are so excited about it.
但你听到了吗？这是我的挣扎，你们。有一系列被删减的谈话头，每个人，就像办公室里的人都在对“精致事物俱乐部”做出反应，就像梅雷迪思很烦，安吉拉很烦。我无法说，而且我现在仍然不能说，“精致事物”、“精致事物俱乐部”。你一直想把它变成复数。你说“精致事物”、“精致事物俱乐部”。我认为这是南方口音。
But did you hear that? This was my struggle, you guys. There's a series of talking heads that were deleted where everyone, like in the office is reacting to the Finer's Things Club and like Meredith is annoyed, Angela is annoyed. I could not say, and I still can't, Finers Things, Finer Things Club. You keep wanting to make it plural. You say Finers, Finers Things Club. I think this is a Southern thing.
我妈妈也这样。我们把东西变成复数，当它们不应该被变成复数时，然后我们把东西变成单数，当它们不应该被变成单数时。就像我妈妈总是说，你看过《办公室》吗，我女儿的《办公室》？而不是《办公室》。是的。然后我说“精致事物俱乐部”。总之，我会把它放在我们的故事里，因为我找到了它。
My mom does this too. We make things plural. when they're not meant to be, and then we make things singular when they're not meant to be. Like my mom always says, have you seen office, my daughter's own office? Instead of the office. Yeah. And then I say Finer's Things Club. Anyway, I'm going to put it in our stories because I found it.
我无法说“精致事物”。精致。精致事物俱乐部，该死。而且，你还会了解到安吉拉·马丁一直在打压其他俱乐部。她真的很烦，因为“精致事物俱乐部”没有得到派对策划委员会的批准。哇。你必须让你的俱乐部得到批准？显然，你必须让它们得到派对策划委员会的批准。她已经打压了其他叛逆团体。梅雷迪思非常生气，因为她没有被邀请加入“精致事物俱乐部”。她拿着她的大杯饮料，来自
I could not say Finer's Things. Finer. Finer Things Club, dang it. And also, you learn that Angela Martin has been squashing other clubs. And she's really annoyed because the Finer Things Club was not seen. sanctioned by the party planning committee. Wow. You have to get your club sanctioned? Apparently, you have to get them sanctioned by the party planning committee. And she has squashed other renegade groups. Meredith is so mad that she's not asked to be in the finer things club. She has her big gulp from
7-11，我敢肯定里面装满了成人饮料。扔在地上。真的吗？人们因为没被邀请而感到愤怒和困扰。好吧，这就是俱乐部里的人。M、奥斯卡和托比。这就是他们在“精致事物俱乐部”里做的事情。他们庆祝书籍、艺术和文化。但没有纸，没有塑料，也不允许谈论工作。帕姆在她的谈话头里说，这非常排外。我也喜欢珍娜，我们了解到奥斯卡不喜欢吉姆的喜剧。不喜欢他的段子，因为他不想让吉姆加入俱乐部。不。因为吉姆会讲喜剧段子。这真的让我笑了。这就是我喜欢我们剧集的地方。是一种假设的历史。我们没有深入探讨。但要知道奥斯卡已经受够了吉姆那些小段子。是的。我喜欢“精致事物俱乐部”的一切。你知道，我曾经参加过一个读书俱乐部，我们会根据书的主题举办主题晚餐，和我们看到的俱乐部所做的事情非常相似。
7-11 that I'm sure is full of adult beverage. throws it on the ground. Really? People are hot and bothered that they haven't been invited. Well, here's who's in the club. M. Oscar and Toby. And here's what they do in the Finer Things Club. They celebrate books, art, and culture. But there is no paper, no plastic, and no work talk allowed. Pam says in her talking head, it's very exclusive. I also love Jenna that we learned that Oscar does not care for Jim's comedy. Doesn't care for his bits because he doesn't want Jim in the club. No. Because Jim does comedy bits. That really made me laugh. This is the thing I love about our show. is an assumed history. We don't go into it. But just know that Oscar has had it with Jim's little bits that he does. Yeah. I love everything about the Finer Things Club. You know, I was in a book club and we would have themed dinners based on the books, very similar to what we see the club doing.
哦天哪，太棒了。顺便说一句，我们有一个来自詹妮弗·古德的粉丝提问。她说，你们能谈谈你们是如何拍摄像“精致事物俱乐部”那样的蒙太奇的吗？你们是一次性拍摄完，然后在中间换衣服让它看起来像不同的日子吗？那是怎么运作的？好吧，是的，詹妮弗，那正是我们所做的。我们花了一个上午，我们会穿上我们的小装束，他们会为一个小段子布置休息室，然后我们拍摄它，我们回到我们的拖车，当我们换衣服时，他们会更换布景。我们只是这样做，直到我们有了所有不同的蒙太奇片段。是的，我们其他人那天开始得比较晚。我们有很晚的通告时间。好吧，珍娜，这是“精致事物俱乐部”的阅读清单，以及关于他们艺术和音乐选择的一点点内容。他们目前正在阅读《看得见风景的房间》，这是E.M.福斯特的小说。在闪回中，我们看到他们正在阅读《精灵之家》，也就是原名《La Casa de los Espiritos》。它是伊莎贝尔·阿连德的作品。然后他们正在阅读阿瑟·高登的《艺伎回忆录》。珍娜，我稍微深入挖掘了一下他们在4分04秒分析的那幅画。哦，是什么？它也是我拍过的你最喜欢的屏幕截图之一。好的。
Oh my gosh, amazing. And by the way, we had a fan question from Jennifer Good. She said, can you talk about how you film a montage like the one with the Finer Things Club? Do you film it all at once and just change your clothes in between to make it look like different days. How does that work? Well, yes, Jennifer, that's exactly what we did. We took a whole morning and we would dress up in our little outfit and they would set up the break room for one bit and then we would film it and we'd go back to our trailers and while we changed clothes, they would change the set. And we just did that until we had all of the different montage pieces. Yes, and the rest of us got a late start that day. We had late call times. Well, Jenna, here's the Finer Things Club reading list and a little bit about
我可能会把它用作你的联系人照片。哦，天哪。奥斯卡指着这幅画。有一场辩论。你们戴着贝雷帽。你们在吃可丽饼，你们把手举在空中。这太美妙了。好的，所以我看到在一些网站上，人们说，
their art and music selection. They are currently reading a room with a view, which is a novel by E.M. Forster. In flashbacks, we see them reading The House of Spirits, also known by its original title is La Casa de los Espiritos. It's by Isabel Allende. Then they are reading memoirs of a geisha by Arthur Golden. Jenna, I did a little bit of a deep dive of the paint they're analyzing at four minutes and four seconds. Ooh, what is it? It's also one of my favorite screen grabs of you I have ever taken. Okay.
有人有关于“精致事物俱乐部”那幅画的信息吗？我要告诉你，这一点。这幅画叫《莫奈在工作室船上作画》，1874年，爱德华·马奈。这是马奈画的莫奈。马奈画了莫奈。所以克劳德·莫奈和爱德华·马奈是朋友。他们是艺术家朋友。克劳德·莫奈有这艘船，他会划出去作画。
I might use it as my contact photo for you. Oh, boy. Oscar is pointing at this painting. There's a debate. You're wearing berets. You're eating crapes and you are throwing your hand in the air. It's just wonderful. Okay, so I saw on a few sites that people were like,
我可能会把它用作我手机里你的联系人头像。天哪。奥斯卡正指着这幅画。这里有个争议。你们戴着贝雷帽，吃着可丽饼，还把手举在空中。这真是太棒了。好吧，我在一些网站上看到人们在问，
does anyone have any information about the painting of the Finer's Things Club? I'm going to tell you, this point. This painting is called Monet painting in his studio boat, 1874, by Eduard Manet. It's a Manet of Monet. Manet painted Monet. So Claude Monet and Edward Manet were friends. They were artist friends. And Claude Monet had this boat that he would go out in and he would paint.
有人知道关于“精致事物俱乐部”那幅画的信息吗？我来告诉你们，这幅画叫《莫奈在工作室船上作画》，1874年，由爱德华·马奈创作。这是一幅马奈画的莫奈。马奈画了莫奈。所以克劳德·莫奈和爱德华·马奈是朋友。他们是艺术家朋友。克劳德·莫奈有一艘船，他会划船出去作画。
And Manet painted his friend in his boat painting a picture. and I have seen it online mislabeled. For example, at Wayfair, they sell a print of this. They have it titled, Monet, painting in his studio by Claude Monet. So I wrote Wayfair. I wrote them. You wrote them? I did.
马奈画了他的朋友在船上画画。我在网上看到它被贴错了标签。例如，在Wayfair网站上，他们出售这张画的印刷品。他们将其命名为《莫奈在工作室里作画》，作者是克劳德·莫奈。所以我写信给Wayfair。我写信给他们。你写信给他们了？是的。
I went into their comments and question section, and I said, you have this mislabeled. This is Monet painting in a studio boat by Edward Mane. I look forward to seeing if that gets changed. I hope it does. You can go to www. manet.org to learn more about Edouard Manet. This is a fan question from Lauren Harris, DeBani T, Maria H, and Nicole P.
我进入了他们的评论和提问区，我说，你们的标签贴错了。这是爱德华·马奈画的《莫奈在工作室船上作画》。我很期待看到它是否会被修改。我希望会。你可以访问www.manet.org了解更多关于爱德华·马奈的信息。这是一个来自Lauren Harris、DeBani T、Maria H和Nicole P的粉丝提问。
Wanting to know if I have read any of the books that were featured in the different clips from the Finer Things Club. I have read none of them. What? No. Lady, I have read A Room with a View, Memoirs of a Gatia, and Angela's Ashes.
想知道我是否读过“精致事物俱乐部”不同片段中提到的任何书籍。我一本都没读过。什么？不。女士，我读过《看得见风景的房间》、《艺伎回忆录》和《安琪拉的灰烬》。
Wow! How are they? I should be in the finer things club. Wow. I have to say watching this episode, I thought this is a good reading list. It is. This would make a good book club. Yeah, the only one I haven't read is the House of the Spirits, but I want to because I read a little bit about what it's about and I think it's really interesting. Should we read it together? Oh my gosh. Should we do a book club of the House of the Spirits? Well, I've really been reading a lot of nonfiction this past year and I am on the a lookout for a great couple of fiction books. So maybe this is where I should start. Okay. I'm inspired. Well, maybe the House of the Spirits. Jenna, let's start a little book club. Let's do it. Who wants to read it with us? Read it with us. Kim would be called the Finers Things Club. Yes, ours is called the Finers Things Club in honor of Angela. Because I won't ever get it right otherwise. I like it. Well, now Michael has called Karen. He starts the call with Philip Ellers. How are they hanging? Yeah. Way to go, Michael. And he tells her, look, I'll give you
哇！它们怎么样？我应该加入精致事物俱乐部。哇。我不得不说，看这一集时，我觉得这是一个很好的书单。确实是。这会是一个很好的读书俱乐部。是的，唯一我没读过的是《精灵之屋》，但我很想读，因为我读了一些关于它的介绍，我觉得它真的很有趣。我们要一起读吗？天哪。我们要成立一个《精灵之屋》读书俱乐部吗？嗯，过去这一年我读了很多非虚构类书籍，我正在寻找几本很棒的小说。所以也许这就是我应该开始的地方。好的。我被激励了。嗯，也许就读《精灵之屋》。Jenna，我们来成立一个小小的读书俱乐部吧。我们开始吧。谁想和我们一起读？和我们一起读吧。Kim，它会被称为“精致事物俱乐部”。是的，我们的俱乐部叫“精致事物俱乐部”，以纪念Angela。因为否则我永远也记不住正确的名字。我喜欢这个名字。好吧，现在Michael给Karen打了电话。他以“Philip Ellers，最近怎么样？”作为开场白。是的。干得好，Michael。然后他告诉她，听着，我会给你
Toby. You can't take Stanley. Take Toby. And then he can't even get through it. He's trying to upsell Toby. He's like, he's smart. He's like, forget it. Toby's the worst. And then he says, you know what? If you take Stanley, I'm going to take your best salesperson. She's like, goodbye, Michael. And he's like, wait, before you go, can you just transfer me to your best salesperson? I know, and she hangs up on him. So Pam connects Michael with Utica's top salesperson, and Michael pitches him a job in Scranton. Ben Nugent, top salesperson in Utica.
Toby。你不能带走Stanley。带走Toby吧。然后他甚至说不下去了。他试图推销Toby。他说，他很聪明。他说，算了吧。Toby是最差劲的。然后他说，你知道吗？如果你带走Stanley，我就带走你最好的销售员。她说，再见，Michael。他说，等等，在你走之前，你能把我转接给你最好的销售员吗？我知道，然后她挂断了他的电话。所以Pam把Michael转接给了Utica的顶级销售员，Michael向他推销了Scranton的一个职位。Ben Nugent，Utica的顶级销售员。
We had a fan question about Ben Nugent, Angela, from Amanda Massa, Jennifer Neal, and Casey Kraft, who is the voice of Ben Nugent from Utica? Well, guys, it was our writer, Lester Lewis. Oh, oh, I didn't know that. I love hearing that. Yeah. And Ben Nugent, the character, was named after Mindy Kaling's real-life boyfriend at the time, writer Benjamin Nugent. I remember them dating.
我们有一个关于Ben Nugent的粉丝提问，Angela，来自Amanda Massa、Jennifer Neal和Casey Kraft，Utica的Ben Nugent的声音是谁？嗯，伙计们，那是我们的编剧Lester Lewis。哦，哦，我不知道。我很高兴听到这个。是的。而Ben Nugent这个角色是以Mindy Kaling当时现实生活中的男朋友，编剧Benjamin Nugent的名字命名的。我记得他们当时在约会。
That didn't even register when I was watching this. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. Wow. That's some good little tidbits there, Jenna. Well, I love how Michael starts this call with him. He said, hey, do you like magic? Because I'm a genie in a bottle. And I'm going to grant you three wishes to move to Scranton to have a great job and to be my best friend. Cuckoo Pants. I know. Could you imagine getting a call like that? No. And of course, Ben just shuts him down. He's like, yeah, I heard you're the guy that hit a woman with a car. Like, he's just not into it. And this is when Michael has this talking head where he says, Scranton isn't lame. It's cool. We're like the fun branch. And that's where that extended talking head would have come, where he breaks down all the branches.
我看这一集的时候甚至都没注意到。是的。天哪。哇。Jenna，这真是一些不错的小花絮。嗯，我喜欢Michael开始这通电话的方式。他说，嘿，你喜欢魔术吗？因为我是瓶子里的精灵。我要满足你三个愿望：搬到Scranton，拥有一份很棒的工作，并成为我最好的朋友。疯子。我知道。你能想象接到这样的电话吗？不能。当然，Ben直接拒绝了他。他说，是的，我听说你就是那个开车撞了女人的家伙。就像，他根本不感兴趣。这就是Michael进行那段谈话的时候，他说，Scranton并不无聊。它很酷。我们就像是有趣的分部。这就是那段加长谈话出现的地方，他分析了所有的分部。
Oh, amazing. Michael and Dwight storm into the break room where the Finer Things Club is setting up. They have some Vivaldi playing in the background. The scene is so funny. I don't know how you guys got through it, but you couldn't. I saw the bloopers. You guys were losing it. Listen, every time Toby walks in and he's wearing his bow tie and Michael reacts to him, Paul could not get through that moment. He laughed every time Steve looked at him. It took us so long to get through that. It was so funny. You guys have to watch these bloopers.
哦，太棒了。Michael和Dwight冲进休息室，精致事物俱乐部正在那里布置。背景里放着维瓦尔第的音乐。这一幕太搞笑了。我不知道你们是怎么演完的，但你们没能忍住。我看了花絮。你们都笑场了。听着，每次Toby走进来，戴着他的领结，Michael对他做出反应时，Paul都无法完成那一刻。每次Steve看着他，他都会笑。我们花了很长时间才拍完。太搞笑了。你们一定要看这些花絮。
He's walking in with like stacked china teacups. And there is a time that Steve broke, which you guys know was rare. But Steve completely broke in one of the. bluepers. Paulus Toby just says bow tie. It was so amazing. It was so good. Well, anyway, the purpose of this scene was that Dwight and Michael full on lie to Jim. So Michael and Dwight have this whole ruse to get Jim to go to Utica with them. They tell them that this company has lost the Staples account and they're going to go and they're going to get it and Jim has to come with them. So off they go. Yeah. Yeah. So they're in the car.
他走进来，手里拿着一叠茶杯。有一次Steve笑场了，你们知道这很少见。但Steve在其中一个花絮里完全笑场了。Paul饰演的Toby只是说了“领结”。太神奇了。太棒了。好吧，无论如何，这一幕的目的是Dwight和Michael完全是在对Jim撒谎。所以Michael和Dwight有一个诡计，想让Jim和他们一起去Utica。他们告诉他，这家公司失去了Staples的客户，他们要去把它抢回来，Jim必须和他们一起去。于是他们出发了。是的。是的。所以他们在车里。
And Jim notices, oh, no, wait, you missed the exit. And that's when Dwight and Michael are like, we have a surprise for you. Jim is immediately, immediately terrified. The look on Rain's face in the backseat is Dwight. He could barely contain, like, how giddy he was, that they roped Jim into this. And Michael's like, we're going on a panty raid to Utica. Oh, my God. Oh, my gosh.
Jim注意到，哦，不，等等，你错过了出口。就在那时，Dwight和Michael说，我们有一个惊喜给你。Jim立刻，立刻感到恐惧。Rain在后座上的表情就是Dwight。他几乎无法抑制自己把Jim拉进这件事的兴奋感。Michael说，我们要去Utica进行一次“内裤突袭”。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
And Jim's like, no, no. He gets out his cell phone. He's going to make a phone call. But Dwight grabs it and throws his phone out the window. Yeah. Throws his phone out the window. And also, Michael says, had to be done. Had to be done.
Jim说，不，不。他拿出手机。他要打个电话。但Dwight抢过手机，把它扔出了窗外。是的。把它扔出了窗外。而且，Michael说，必须得这么做。必须得这么做。
What? What? We had a fan question from I.C. Lee and Emily Jones. When they threw Jim's phone out the window, did someone have to go pick it up behind the car? Was that a real phone? Okay, it was a real phone. And yes, we had a follow car, which is. a car that follows the actors, and they would have to stop and pick up that phone.
什么？什么？我们有一个来自I.C. Lee和Emily Jones的粉丝提问。当他们把Jim的手机扔出窗外时，有人必须去车后捡回来吗？那是真手机吗？好吧，那是真手机。是的，我们有一辆跟随车，也就是跟随演员的车，他们必须停下来捡起那个手机。
Yeah. We had a fan catch from Doug Schmidt, who says, not a question, but when Dwight throws Jim's phone out the window, they are clearly on a four-lane road, but when they stop to find it, it's only a two-lane road. Oh, look at you with your catch, Doug. You go. And another catch from Emily Ambris at 8 minutes, 45 seconds, when they've stopped to retrieve the phone, you can see a road sign that says San Fernando in a fourth of a mile. Oh, that's a really good
是的。我们有一个来自Doug Schmidt的粉丝发现，他说，不是一个问题，但当Dwight把Jim的手机扔出窗外时，他们显然是在一条四车道的路上，但当他们停下来找它时，却变成了一条双车道的路。哦，看看你，Doug，你发现了。干得好。还有来自Emily Ambris的另一个发现，在8分45秒时，当他们停下来取回手机时，你可以看到一个路标，上面写着“San Fernando，四分之一英里”。哦，那真是一个很好的
catch. So yeah, clearly in California. So they're looking for Jim's phone. Jim finds it. And he's like, you know what? I'm going to call a cab. And they're like, okay, well, you'll miss out on the pranks. And he's like, hold up. What are you guys doing? What do you have planned? And then Michael lists off. They have the warehouse uniforms, silly string. Dwight also has some gasoline and chunks of rubber to make stink bombs or real bombs. They don't know. Yeah. Could be badass. They don't know. It could be either one. And Jim's like, yeah, no, that's not happening. So he makes a deal with him that he'll dress up in the warehouse uniform. By the way, the one he got was Madges. Yes. And that he will go with them, but no stink bombs are shenanigans. Yeah, this is the compromise that he makes. And from this
发现。所以是的，显然是在加利福尼亚。所以他们在找Jim的手机。Jim找到了它。他说，你知道吗？我要叫出租车。他们说，好吧，那你就会错过恶作剧了。他说，等等。你们在做什么？你们有什么计划？然后Michael列举了一堆。他们有仓库制服、彩带喷雾。Dwight还有一些汽油和橡胶块，用来制作臭气弹或真正的炸弹。他们不知道。是的。可能是个狠角色。他们不知道。可能是其中任何一个。Jim说，是的，不，那是不可能的。所以他与他们达成协议，他会穿上仓库制服。顺便说一句，他拿到的那件是Madge的。是的。他会和他们一起去，但不能有臭气弹或恶作剧。是的，这就是他做出的妥协。从这个
talking head, it cuts to this silent moment in the car, nine minutes, 45 seconds, the three of them in the uniforms with these ridiculous mustaches. It is such a funny cut too. It cracked me up. I have so much to say about these car scenes, but I think we should take a break and come back and really get into it. Have you ever peed in a bottle in the backseat of a car? I have not, have you? I thought about it real serious. I've peed on the side of a lot of roads. Same. Okay. Well, more to discuss when we come back. We are back, and the boys are in the car. They've got their outfits on.
谈话片段，切换到车里的沉默时刻，9分45秒，他们三个穿着制服，戴着荒谬的胡子。这一剪辑也太搞笑了。我笑得前仰后合。关于这些车内场景我有很多话要说，但我认为我们应该休息一下，回来后再深入探讨。你曾经在车后座往瓶子里撒过尿吗？我没有，你呢？我认真考虑过。我在很多路边撒过尿。我也是。好吧。回来后还有更多要讨论的。我们回来了，男人们在车里。他们穿上了他们的服装。
They've got their mustaches on. They're driving to Utica. Michael is asking Jim a lot of questions about his breakup with Karen. And Jim doesn't want to talk about it. So Jim is like, let's play that alphabet game that you want to play. Yes. And Michael's like, okay, A is for Alan. And he's married to Alice and they live in Alaska and they sell.
他们戴上了胡子。他们正开车去Utica。Michael问了Jim很多关于他和Karen分手的问题。Jim不想谈论这个。所以Jim说，我们来玩那个你想玩的字母游戏吧。是的。Michael说，好的，A代表Alan。他娶了Alice，他们住在阿拉斯加，他们卖。
What do they sell? What do they sell? And then he's like, wait, what is that noise? I hear, is that water like in the engine? Like, what is that air conditioner leaking? What's that sound? Oh, that sound is Dwight peeing in a can in the back seat. And they freak out.
他们卖什么？他们卖什么？然后他说，等等，那是什么声音？我听到了，那是引擎里的水声吗？就像，那是空调在漏水吗？那是什么声音？哦，那个声音是Dwight在后座的罐子里撒尿。他们吓坏了。
They're like, oh, gross. And then Michael starts swerving and Dwight's like, you're making me spray. The scene is like so fun to watch. I was laughing so hard. We got a lot of mail about the scene. One from Sadie K. Who says, when the guys were in the car, did they break a lot? Oh, Sadie, the bloopers from the scene are so worth it.
他们说，哦，真恶心。然后Michael开始转向，Dwight说，你让我喷出来了。这一幕看起来太有趣了。我笑得太厉害了。我们收到了很多关于这一幕的邮件。一位来自Sadie K的观众说，当他们在车里时，他们笑场了很多次吗？哦，Sadie，这一幕的花絮太值得看了。
You've got to watch it. They were cracking up. I mean, it's one of the like rare times where Steve could not keep it together. Steve. Yeah. Every time, too. Rain would have to say, I think I cut my penis on the lid. And then this is in the deleted scenes, but it's also in the bloopers.
你一定要看。他们笑得前仰后合。我的意思是，这是Steve无法控制自己的罕见时刻之一。Steve。是的。每次都这样。Rain不得不说，我想我的阴茎被盖子割伤了。然后这在删减片段里，但也在花絮里。
At the very end, Dwight goes, I cut a chunk out of my penis for nothing. Those guys could not get through it. They were like melting into laughter. I mean, just imagine being in a car together, these three comedic actors at the top of their game. I mean, brilliant. We had another fan question from Evan Derrickson. This is a technical question. Evan wants to know who got to decide who wears which mustache because they're really perfect for each character and so funny.
最后，Dwight说，我为了什么都没得到而割掉了一块阴茎。那些家伙根本无法完成拍摄。他们笑得融化了。我的意思是，想象一下这三个处于事业巅峰的喜剧演员在一起开车。我的意思是，太棒了。我们还有另一个来自Evan Derrickson的粉丝提问。这是一个技术性问题。Evan想知道是谁决定谁戴哪种胡子，因为它们真的很适合每个角色，而且太搞笑了。
Is that a wardrobe thing? Does it need Greg's approval? Is it props? Well, Evan, I like your question because you've clearly been listening to Office Ladies. The mustaches are made by hair and makeup. So it's not a prop. And hair and makeup work together because it's hair, because it's a mustache, right? Yeah.
这是服装部门的事吗？需要Greg的批准吗？是道具吗？嗯，Evan，我喜欢你的问题，因为你显然一直在听《办公室女士》。胡子是由发型和化妆部门制作的。所以它不是道具。发型和化妆部门一起工作，因为它是头发，因为它是胡子，对吧？是的。
But then it goes on the face and has to be applied to the face. So it becomes a makeup thing. So they just had a tray of a bunch of different mustaches. And yes, they got Greg's approval. They talked to Joss Whedon, the director. They talked to Mindy Kaling. And they picked the mustaches for each of these guys to wear. Hair and makeup would take photos of the guys with the different mustaches.
但它要贴在脸上，必须应用到脸上。所以它变成了化妆的事。所以他们只是准备了一个托盘，上面有各种不同的胡子。是的，他们得到了Greg的批准。他们和导演Joss Whedon谈过。他们和Mindy Kaling谈过。他们为每个人挑选了要戴的胡子。发型和化妆部门会给戴着不同胡子的人拍照。
and then walk them over to the writer's room and the writers and directors would look at it. I can't imagine. That is so funny to me. Well, next up, the Finer Things Club meeting is underway. Yes, and at 10 minutes, 50 seconds, we have a Pam's teapot catch. Yes, that's right. They are using Pam's teapot that Jim gave her in that very first Christmas episode. I have a question for the Finer Things Club.
然后把照片带到编剧室，编剧和导演会看。我无法想象。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，接下来，精致事物俱乐部会议正在进行中。是的，在10分50秒，我们有一个Pam的茶壶发现。是的，没错。他们正在使用Jim在第一集圣诞节送给她的那个茶壶。我有一个问题要问精致事物俱乐部。
Yes? How much stuff do you have to bring to work on the day that you guys meet? There is a three-tiered tray of sandwiches, a tablecloth, flatware, the teapot, the cups. You're like bringing a crate of stuff. Yeah, don't worry about it. Doesn't involve you. We got it covered. They're discussing a room with a view and who walks in, but Andy.
是的？你们开会那天要带多少东西去上班？有一个三层三明治托盘、桌布、餐具、茶壶、杯子。你们就像带了一箱东西。是的，别担心。不关你的事。我们搞定了。他们正在讨论《看得见风景的房间》，谁进来了，是Andy。
He wants to be in the club. And Pam tells them it's a closed club. She's very direct and unapologetic. I'm sorry. This is a closed club. And Andy has a talking head where he says, The Finer Things Club is the most exclusive club in the office. So it's naturally where he needs to be.
他想加入俱乐部。Pam告诉他这是一个封闭的俱乐部。她非常直接且毫不歉疚。抱歉。这是一个封闭的俱乐部。Andy有一个谈话片段，他说，精致事物俱乐部是办公室里最独特的俱乐部。所以这自然是他需要待的地方。
Party planning committee is his backup. Kevin's band is his safety. Everything is like he's rushing a fraternity. It's so true. It's so true. Well, I'll have you know we loved shooting these scenes. Me, Oscar, Paul. We were delighted by this storyline. We had the best time because this was a group of people that did not normally get to hang out. I did not have a lot of scenes with Oscar or Paul. So this was really cool. And I'll have you know that before the pandemic, we had a Finer Things Club reunion lunch. You did. I thought this was so, so sweet. When you told me you guys were all going to meet, I was like, that. is adorable. Yeah. We met. We had lunch and we invited Ed. Oh. We let Ed come. So the four of us had this amazing lunch. I took a picture, so I'll post it in the pot. That is so sweet. I'm very sad I wasn't
派对策划委员会是他的后备。Kevin的乐队是他的安全网。一切就像他在参加兄弟会一样。太真实了。太真实了。好吧，我得告诉你，我们很喜欢拍摄这些场景。我和Oscar、Paul。我们对这个故事情节感到非常高兴。我们度过了最美好的时光，因为这是一群平时不怎么在一起玩的人。我和Oscar或Paul没有太多对手戏。所以这真的很酷。我得告诉你，在疫情之前，我们举行了一次精致事物俱乐部重聚午餐。你们真的去了。我觉得这太贴心了。当你告诉我你们都要见面时，我就觉得，这太可爱了。是的。我们见面了。我们吃了午餐，还邀请了Ed。哦。我们让Ed来了。所以我们四个人吃了这顿很棒的午餐。我拍了张照片，我会把它发在播客里。这太贴心了。我很遗憾我没有
invited on the show or in real life. Well, I'll say we did not discuss any literature or art at our reunion lunch. We just chatted about our lives and our kids. Well, now the guys have rolled up to the But Janah, first I want to talk to you about a deleted scene. You will not believe this scene. I had Sam pull this clip. Jim has called Pam from the road with Michael and Dwight. And Pam is kind of passive aggressively given Jim a little shade for seeing Karen. Oh, I don't even remember doing this scene. I couldn't believe it. It just doesn't even sound like Pam to me. And I think there's a reason it was deleted, but it's pretty delicious to listen to. Sam, can you play it? Wait, you're going along with this now? I have to. Pam, if I'm not there, someone's
被邀请参加节目或现实生活中的聚会。好吧，我会说我们在重聚午餐上没有讨论任何文学或艺术。我们只是聊了聊我们的生活和孩子。好吧，现在男人们已经开车到了，但Jenna，首先我想和你谈谈一个删减片段。你不会相信这个场景。我让Sam找了这个片段。Jim在和Michael、Dwight在路上时给Pam打了电话。Pam有点被动攻击地因为Jim去见Karen而对他冷嘲热讽。哦，我甚至不记得拍过这个场景。我简直不敢相信。这听起来甚至不像Pam。我想它被删掉是有原因的，但听起来确实很有趣。Sam，你能播放一下吗？等等，你现在要顺着他了吗？我必须这么做。Pam，如果我不去，有人会
going to go to jail or die. Right. And you wouldn't be able to talk to Karen. Well, I promise you that it has nothing to do with it. A little bit. Well, yeah, I don't want to see her get physically harmed, that's for sure. Because you love her? Because you love her very much. All right, I'm going to go now. Okay, have fun with your girlfriend. Okay, I will. I mean, Jenna, you're going to have fun with your little girlfriend? Oh my gosh, Pam is totally jealous. I don't know. Do you think she's really jealous?
坐牢或死掉。对。而且你将无法和Karen说话。好吧，我向你保证这和那没关系。有一点点。好吧，是的，我不想看到她受到身体伤害，那是肯定的。因为你爱她？因为你非常爱她。好了，我要走了。好的，和你女朋友玩得开心。好的，我会的。我的意思是，Jenna，你要和你的小女朋友玩得开心？天哪，Pam完全是在吃醋。我不知道。你觉得她真的吃醋了吗？
Yes, Pam also has a talking head where she's like, I was just kidding. We kid like that. And then she's like, okay, maybe I'm a little jealous. Wow, I don't even remember shooting that. Yeah. That's so crazy. You have to watch the deleted scenes. That does sound a little bit like me when I'm being passive aggressive.
是的，Pam还有一个谈话片段，她说，我只是在开玩笑。我们就是那样开玩笑的。然后她说，好吧，也许我有一点吃醋。哇，我甚至不记得拍过那个。是的。太疯狂了。你一定要看删减片段。当我表现得被动攻击时，那听起来确实有点像我。
That was more Jenna than Pam. Maybe a little bit. I think it's good that they deleted it because I think I like instead, you know, that he comes back at the end of the day. And, you know, I don't know. I don't want to see that side of Pam. Yeah, I just don't think we need that tension in the relationship. It doesn't need to be about that, you know? Yeah.
那更像是Jenna而不是Pam。也许有一点。我觉得删掉它是好的，因为我觉得我更喜欢他最后一天结束时回来。而且，我不知道。我不想看到Pam的那一面。是的，我只是觉得我们不需要关系中的那种紧张感。没必要那样，你知道吗？是的。
I like it and we'll get to it that Jim and Karen are going to have a moment where they have to deal with their stuff. But I like that Pam is left out of it. Yeah, me too. So now the guys roll up to the Utica branch and Michael reveals. their plan. They're going to pretend to be warehouse workers and they're going to silly string the whole place. Dwight adds that he might stab the security guy in the eye with a piece of jumbo chalk. And Jim is like, you're not stabbing anyone in the eye. Dwight's like, okay, fine. Maybe I'll just grind it up and blow it in his eyes. Yeah. He has a talking head that he says the eyes are the
我喜欢这一点，我们稍后会谈到Jim和Karen会有一个必须处理他们问题的时刻。但我喜欢Pam被排除在外。是的，我也是。所以现在男人们开车到了Utica分部，Michael揭示了他们的计划。他们要假装成仓库工人，他们要用彩带喷雾喷满整个地方。Dwight补充说，他可能会用一块巨大的粉笔刺伤保安的眼睛。Jim说，你不能刺伤任何人的眼睛。Dwight说，好吧，好吧。也许我只是把它磨碎吹进他的眼睛里。是的。他有一个谈话片段，他说眼睛是
groin of the head. Yeah. So look out eyeballs if Dwight's around. I really really. love that line. I did too. Dwight and Michael leave and Jim is now on a walkie-talkie in the car. Well, and he sees Karen. He's like, oh my God, she's here. Go, go, go. And he leans the seat back, trying to hide from Karen. Yeah. But in the meantime, through the walkie-talkie, we only hear it, which I personally think is so freaking funny. Michael and Dwight decide to steal the industrial copier. Then you hear a very loud crashing noise. And then you see a very loud crashing noise. And then you start to hear Michael talking about his hip. He's saying, Jim, save us. He's saying, Jim, if this is my last moment, please tell me you'll take over the Dundees. It's so, so amazing.
头部的腹股沟。是的。所以如果Dwight在附近，小心眼球。我真的，真的喜欢那句台词。我也喜欢。Dwight和Michael离开了，Jim现在在车里用对讲机。嗯，他看到了Karen。他说，天哪，她在那儿。快，快，快。他把座位向后靠，试图躲避Karen。是的。但与此同时，通过对讲机，我们只能听到声音，我个人认为这太搞笑了。Michael和Dwight决定偷走工业复印机。然后你听到一声非常响亮的撞击声。然后你看到一声非常响亮的撞击声。然后你开始听到Michael谈论他的臀部。他说，Jim，救救我们。他说，Jim，如果这是我最后的时刻，请告诉我你会接管Dundees。太，太神奇了。
And Jenna, you're so right. It was better over the walkie-talkie. There's a deleted scene in the stairwell where Michael is pinned by the copier and there's silly string everywhere and the security guards have come and it just plays funnier over the walkie-talkie. really does. So I was really glad that they made that choice. I have a fan catch for this moment. Okay. When the guys were driving in the car, it was very clear that there was just Michael, Jim, and then Dwight in the back seat. But now all of a sudden, we have a camera operator in the car with Jim. Yeah. And Jim is like, get down. What are you doing? You know, where did this guy come from? And also, when they're on the side of the road, there was clearly a camera operator on the side of the road with
Jenna，你说得太对了。通过对讲机听更好。楼梯间有一个删减片段，Michael被复印机压住了，到处都是彩带喷雾，保安也来了，通过对讲机播放确实更搞笑。真的。所以我很高兴他们做了那个选择。我有一个关于这一刻的粉丝发现。好的。当男人们开车时，很明显只有Michael、Jim，然后是后座的Dwight。但现在突然之间，我们有一个摄像师在Jim的车里。是的。Jim说，趴下。你在做什么？你知道，这家伙从哪儿冒出来的？而且，当他们在路边时，显然有一个摄像师在路边和
them. So I have made up a story in my head that the camera operators followed them in another vehicle to document this moment. They had a huge budget. They put lipstick cameras in the car, rigged the car, then followed the car with a second set of handheld cameras. This PBS went all out. They really did. Well, they knew that this was going to be a good moment. Yeah. We had a fan question from Aris Beth Cruz, Zufan Girard, Colby Shannon, and Caro B. Were Jim Michael and Dwight actually talking through walkie-talkies? Yes, they were. And I don't know if this was in the bloopers, Angela, but John was laughing so hard at what he was listening to. I remember him telling me stories, wait until you see this scene. These guys were so funny over the walkie-talkie. I loved when
他们在一起。所以我编了一个故事，摄像师跟着他们坐另一辆车来记录这一刻。他们有巨大的预算。他们在车里放了口红摄像机，改装了车，然后用第二组手持摄像机跟着车。这个PBS真是全力以赴。他们确实做到了。好吧，他们知道这将是一个很好的时刻。是的。我们有一个来自Aris Beth Cruz、Zufan Girard、Colby Shannon和Caro B的粉丝提问。Jim、Michael和Dwight真的在用对讲机说话吗？是的，他们是。我不知道这是否在花絮里，Angela，但John在听的时候笑得太厉害了。我记得他告诉我故事，等着看这一幕吧。这些家伙在对讲机里太搞笑了。我喜欢当
Jim kept saying, stop saying my name. Yes. Yes. Well, Karen spots Jim in the car and she walks over. So embarrassing. But then it leads into this amazing scene. She's got the three of them on a couch in her office. It 100% looks like three kids who've been called to the principal's office.
Jim一直说，别再叫我的名字了。是的。是的。好吧，Karen在车里发现了Jim，她走了过来。太尴尬了。但这引出了这个精彩的场景。她把他们三个关在办公室的沙发上。这100%看起来像三个被叫到校长办公室的孩子。
Mm-hmm. Well, Karen is loving this. I mean, there's a whole talking head where she says, I cried for weeks over that guy. So, yeah, it felt pretty good seeing him in this situation. Yeah. The only person's still wearing his mustache now is Dwight. Michael is defending his behavior. He is saying that he cares enough to fight for his employees.
嗯。好吧，Karen很喜欢这样。我的意思是，有一个完整的谈话片段，她说，我为那个家伙哭了几个星期。所以，是的，看到他处于这种境地感觉相当不错。是的。现在唯一还戴着胡子的人是Dwight。Michael在为他的行为辩护。他说他足够关心，愿意为他的员工而战。
And if Stanley comes to Utica and she hurts one hair on his head, he will burn Utica to the ground. Yeah, Dwight and Michael both say they will burn Utica. to the ground. Insane. So Karen sends Michael and Dwight away. She says, Jim, will you stay a moment? Ooh. Oh, the principal kept one.
如果Stanley来到Utica，而她伤了他的一根头发，他就会把Utica夷为平地。是的，Dwight和Michael都说他们会把Utica夷为平地。疯了。所以Karen把Michael和Dwight赶走了。她说，Jim，你能留一会儿吗？哦。哦，校长留下了一个。
Let the other two go. Well, now it's going to get personal. Oh, this is so cringy. She says, Jim, if you wanted to see me, you could have just called. And Jim's like, oh, no, I didn't want to see you. Oh. Oh. And he's like, not that I'm not happy that, you know, to see you, but I know, I was basically
让另外两个走了。好吧，现在要变得私人了。哦，这太尴尬了。她说，Jim，如果你想见我，你本可以直接打电话的。Jim说，哦，不，我不想见你。哦。哦。他说，并不是我不高兴，你知道，见到你，但我知道，我基本上
just here for the copier, because I'm, you know, with Pam and things are going well and, you know, we're good. And she's like, oh, I'm so glad to hear that things are going so well for you. Oh, yeah. Angela, we had a fan catch for this scene from Rachel Watkins. At 17 minutes, 27 seconds, as Karen and Jim are having their one-on-one, Karen has a photo of Hillary Clinton on her bookshelf. Rachel is wondering if this is a nod to Leslie Knope, having framed photos of Hillary Clinton in her office for Parks and Recreation. You know what, Rachel, I don't know, but what a great catch. Yeah, I didn't catch that. I zoomed in on it.
只是为了复印机才来这里的，因为我，你知道，和Pam在一起，事情进展顺利，你知道，我们很好。她说，哦，我很高兴听到你的事情进展得这么顺利。哦，是的。Angela，我们有一个来自Rachel Watkins的粉丝发现。在17分27秒，当Karen和Jim进行一对一谈话时，Karen的书架上有一张Hillary Clinton的照片。Rachel想知道这是否是对Leslie Knope在《公园与游憩》办公室里挂Hillary Clinton照片的致敬。你知道吗，Rachel，我不知道，但这真是一个很棒的发现。是的，我没注意到。我放大了看。
But speaking of Parks and Recreation, Angela, we had another fan question. A bunch of people wrote in. They said, how did you get Rashida Jones back for this? Wasn't she on Parks and Recreation at the time? She was, but you might remember that Parks and Rec was created by Mike Scher, who was one of the office writers. And so our production office just called over to their production office, and they were able to clear her for one day of work. So she came and did this one shooting day at these offices for Utica, but we didn't get to see her. We did not get to have a reunion with her at all because she was on location.
但说到《公园与游憩》，Angela，我们有另一个粉丝提问。很多人写信来。他们说，你们是怎么让Rashida Jones回来拍这一集的？她当时不是在拍《公园与游憩》吗？她是，但你可能记得《公园与游憩》是由Mike Scher创作的，他是《办公室》的编剧之一。所以我们的制作办公室只是给他们的制作办公室打了电话，他们能够让她请假一天。所以她来这里为Utica的办公室拍了这一天，但我们没能见到她。我们根本没能和她重聚，因为她在外景地。
I know. I just thought she crushed these scenes. She was so perfect in them. Well, Jenna, there's a whole lot happening back at Dunder Mifflin because the Finer Things Club is trying to have their meeting. You know, they had to hang a sign. You have to think someone hangs a sign because events have happened, right? Yes, and the solution is a sign.
我知道。我只是觉得她演得太棒了。她在里面太完美了。好吧，Jenna，Dunder Mifflin那边发生了很多事，因为精致事物俱乐部正试图开会。你知道，他们不得不挂一个牌子。你得想，有人挂牌子是因为发生了什么事，对吧？是的，解决方案就是一个牌子。
So they have made a sign at 12 minutes, 49 seconds. You can catch it. It says, Finer Things Club in progress, please be respectful. And Kevin comes in. He's trying to get something out of the video. machine, he's banging it back and forth. His butt is like right up against your chair. And my absolute favorite moment of all of the finer things club meetings is Phyllis and that dang microwave. How many buttons is she hitting? So many buttons. So many buttons. And Oscar, he is so fantastic.
所以他们在12分49秒做了一个牌子。你可以看到它。上面写着，“精致事物俱乐部进行中，请保持尊重”。Kevin进来了。他正试图从视频机里拿出什么东西，他来回敲打它。他的屁股就在你的椅子旁边。我所有精致事物俱乐部会议中最喜欢的一刻是Phyllis和那个该死的微波炉。她按了多少个按钮？太多按钮了。太多按钮了。还有Oscar，他太棒了。
The way he lets it amp up and start to bug him as he's trying to form his thought about his book sharing, right? He wants to tell you guys about this book. Beep, beep, beep, beep. And then finally he just snaps. And he's like, what are you microwaving? And Phyllis says pop karn with her St. Louis accent. We had a lot of people write in and catch that. 1349, you hear a solid pop karn. This is me though, Jenna. I am Oscar. If you want to drive me crazy, have some beeping somewhere. Something beeping makes me nuts. You know, I have to turn off the beeping on my washer dryer. Mm-hmm.
当他试图构思关于他的书籍分享的想法时，他让它放大并开始困扰他，对吧？他想告诉你们关于这本书的事。哔，哔，哔，哔。最后他终于崩溃了。他说，你在用微波炉加热什么？Phyllis用她的圣路易斯口音说“爆米花”。我们有很多人写信来发现了这一点。13分49秒，你听到一个结实的“爆米花”。但这确实是我，Jenna。我就是Oscar。如果你想让我发疯，就在某处弄点哔哔声。有什么东西在哔哔会让我发疯。你知道，我必须关掉洗衣机烘干机的哔哔声。嗯。
I don't need that to keep going off. I know I put the laundry in. Yeah. I know I'll take the laundry out eventually. I'll get to it. I don't need you alarming me to my dry laundry for the next 15 minutes off and on. I don't get why everything has to beep so much. The refrigerator beeps.
我不需要它一直响。我知道我放了衣服进去。是的。我知道我最终会把衣服拿出来。我会去做的。我不需要你为我干了的衣服每隔15分钟就报警一次。我不明白为什么每件事都要哔哔这么多。冰箱会哔哔。
The dishwasher beeps. The microwave beats. My coffee maker beeps. It beeps when it's done and then it beeps when it turns itself off. So much beeping. Can we tone it down on the beeping? Appliance people? Not everything needs an alarm.
洗碗机哔哔。微波炉哔哔。我的咖啡机哔哔。它做完时哔哔，然后它关机时又哔哔。太多的哔哔声了。我们能减少哔哔声吗？家电制造商们？不是每件事都需要警报。
You know? This is, we feel strongly about this. We clearly feel strongly about all the beeping. Unnecessary beeping. Who knew? Well, the guys get back from Utica. Michael gives Stanley his blessing. He says, you know,
你知道吗？这是，我们对此感觉强烈。我们显然对所有的哔哔声感觉强烈。不必要的哔哔声。谁知道呢？好吧，男人们从Utica回来了。Michael给了Stanley他的祝福。他说，你知道，
what, it's okay. And then he gets him a box from the mail cart, Angela. The seldomly used mail cart is getting used. And then he says, Pam, come in my office. I need to write a one ad. And here is Michael's ad that he's going to place for a new employee to take Stanley's place. Are you ready? Well, he's laying on the ground as he dictates this to you. I know. I mean, he has given up all hope. He has failed. And yes, what does he tell you? Wanted. Middle-aged black man with sass. Big butt. Biger heart. I love that Michael used sass. I thought the same thing. And then Stanley's like, I never planned on leaving. I say crazy things sometimes. I was just bluffing and Michael called my bluff. Yeah, he just wanted a raise. He was hoping to leverage this job offer to get more money.
没关系。然后他从邮件车里拿给他一个盒子，Angela。那个很少使用的邮件车正在被使用。然后他说，Pam，进我的办公室。我需要写一个招聘广告。这是Michael要为新员工取代Stanley而发布的广告。你准备好了吗？好吧，他躺在地上向你口述这个。我知道。我的意思是，他已经放弃了所有希望。他失败了。是的，他告诉你什么？招聘。中年黑人，有个性。大屁股。更大的心。我喜欢Michael用了“个性”这个词。我想的一样。然后Stanley说，我从没打算离开。我有时会说些疯狂的话。我只是在虚张声势，而Michael看穿了我的虚张声势。是的，他只是想要加薪。他希望利用这个工作机会来获得更多的钱。
And earlier, when Michael has a meeting with him, he's like, what can I do to get you to stay? And he's like, money, money. But Michael doesn't have the budget. But as it turns out, Stanley's not really going to uproot his family. He's going to stay. Yeah. And him, you know, putting this out there to Michael to see if Michael would like, you know, meet his demands, almost cost Utica getting burned to the ground. I know.
早些时候，当Michael和他开会时，他说，我能做什么让你留下来？他说，钱，钱。但Michael没有预算。但事实证明，Stanley并没有真正要让他的家人搬走。他会留下来。是的。他（你知道）把这个摆在Michael面前，看看Michael是否会（你知道）满足他的要求，差点导致Utica被夷为平地。我知道。
Pam tells Jim, I'm really sorry. Rolando told me everything. I love it that the receptionists talk to one another. I love this so much that you and Rolando have this whole friendship that we don't even know about. I also thought it was pretty great that you said to Jim, how embarrassing. Yeah. I know. Well, when I was chatting with Adam about his time on the office, one of the things he mentioned was that while he was shooting this episode, Rain and Mindy both came up to him and said, we think you could come back. We like this Utica branch idea. We want to have you back and that he was so excited. And then, of course, you know, I go back for lecture circuit. And we had a little fan catch about that. Caitlin Donahue, Sidney Matthews, and Courtney Sage said, in this episode, Pam mentions that she and Rolando talk. But in lecture circuit, Michael introduces Pam to Rolando when they arrive. Is this a continuity error? You know, guys, I just think Michael doesn't know. Michael doesn't know that Pam has these relationships.
Pam告诉Jim，我真的很抱歉。Rolando告诉了我一切。我喜欢接待员们互相交谈。我非常喜欢你和Rolando有这种我们甚至不知道的友谊。我也觉得你对Jim说“多尴尬啊”很棒。是的。我知道。好吧，当我和Adam聊起他在《办公室》的时间时，他提到的事情之一是，当他拍摄这一集时，Rain和Mindy都走过来对他说，我们认为你可以回来。我们喜欢这个Utica分部的想法。我们想让你回来，他当时非常兴奋。然后，当然，你知道，我回去拍“讲座巡回”了。我们对此有一个小小的粉丝发现。Caitlin Donahue、Sidney Matthews和Courtney Sage说，在这一集中，Pam提到她和Rolando交谈。但在“讲座巡回”中，Michael在他们到达时向Pam介绍了Rolando。这是一个连续性错误吗？你知道，伙计们，我只是觉得Michael不知道。Michael不知道Pam有这些关系。
Just like remember earlier, it's clear that Pam and Michael's mother talk to one another as well. Oh, I think there's so much that Michael doesn't know about even what Pam's job does, you know? Like, how about the fact that, like, he's like, Pam, will you hold all my calls today? And Pam's like, sure, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep. Like, Michael doesn't know what Pam does. It's true. To make Jim feel better, Pam invites him to be in the Finer Things Club, and the end of this episode is a flash forward to their next meeting where they are discussing Angela's ashes. And true to Jim Form, he has to do a bit.
就像记得早些时候，很明显Pam和Michael的母亲也会交谈。哦，我觉得Michael甚至不知道Pam的工作是做什么的，你知道吗？比如，他就像是，“Pam，你今天能帮我接听所有电话吗？”Pam说，“好的，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔。”就像，Michael不知道Pam在做什么。这是真的。为了让Jim感觉好点，Pam邀请他加入精致事物俱乐部，这一集的结尾是他们下一次会议的闪回，他们正在讨论《安琪拉的灰烬》。按照Jim的风格，他必须表演一下。
Yep, he's doing his Irish accent. Oscar just kind of looks at him and is like, did you get it all out? And then he hasn't read the book! Oh, Paul is so amazing in this scene. He's like, who's the main character? Jim is like, Angela, no. No, the ashes. No.
是的，他在用他的爱尔兰口音。Oscar只是看着他，好像在说，你都发泄完了吗？然后他还没读那本书！哦，Paul在这一幕里太棒了。他说，主角是谁？Jim说，Angela，不。不，灰烬。不。
And Pam just mouths. Sorry. Well, there are two deleted Andy scenes that I want to discuss before we wrap up. They're about the Finer Things Club and about how desperately he was trying to get in. Because you know, when Pam let Jim in, you saw Andy go, are you kidding me? Right? Yeah. So here are these two things that Anne.
Pam只是口型说：抱歉。好吧，在结束之前，有两个我想讨论的Andy删减场景。它们是关于精致事物俱乐部的，以及他多么绝望地想加入。因为你知道，当Pam让Jim加入时，你看到Andy说，你在开玩笑吗？对吧？是的。所以这里有两件事是Anne。
Andy does. There is a scene where Andy comes in to the break room to you guys and offers you an envelope full of cash, a donation, if you will. There is a scene, Jenna, and the deleted scenes, and I think it would have come towards the end of the episode. You guys, the Finer Things Club, walk up to Andy, you give him a sealed envelope. He opens it up. It's a letter telling him he has been put on the wait list. And he is thrilled. He shared that he was waitlist. He shared that he was waitlisted at Cornell and then his dad donated a whole building to the college. Ah, I see. Oh my gosh. Andy, we learn and deleted scenes was in fact on the wait list. Delicious. Guys, that was Branch Wars. Thank you to Adam Jamal Craig for sending in those audio clips and thank you
Andy做的。有一个场景是Andy走进休息室找你们，给你们一个装满现金的信封，如果你愿意的话，算是一笔捐款。有一个场景，Jenna，在删减片段里，我觉得它应该是在这一集的结尾。你们，精致事物俱乐部，走到Andy面前，你们给了他一个密封的信封。他打开它。这是一封告诉他他被列入候补名单的信。他非常激动。他分享说他被列入候补名单。他分享说他在康奈尔大学被列入候补名单，然后他爸爸给学校捐了一整栋楼。啊，我明白了。哦，天哪。Andy，我们在删减片段里了解到，事实上是在候补名单上。太美味了。伙计们，那是“分部战争”。感谢Adam Jamal Craig发来那些音频片段，也感谢
guys for your questions. Next week, Survivor Man. Ooh. And in the meantime, we will start the Finers Things Club. And what are we? we reading. Our first book will be the House of the Spirits. Ordering now. We'll see you guys next week. Thanks guys. We'll see you next week. Hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill
你们的问题。下周，“幸存者”。哦。在此期间，我们将开始“精致事物俱乐部”。我们要读什么？我们的第一本书将是《精灵之屋》。现在下单。我们下周见。谢谢大家。我们下周见。希望你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Juerkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Bill
Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。